i actually have to say you know how much
i hate to say i told you so
we covered for many many months we've
covered the masks which i've said from
the beginning are extremely stupid
and some people disagreed with me at the
beginning now i think everybody agrees
with me
then then just the other day they said
that there's there's a new rule
everyone's got to start wearing two
masks
and i thought about this for a second i
said wait uh first of all you told us
all not to wear masks then you told us
we had to wear masks then now you're
telling us to wear two masks
i'm no scientist i'm no expert but i
think pretty soon
they're going to be telling us to wear
three masks right i believe i said this
on the show
yesterday or the day before well
tuning into cnbc you can see former fox
news
anchor shepard smith comes out gives a
great big old report on the efficacy the
genius
of wearing three masks since the start
of the pandemic
experts have urged us to do three things
wash our hands maintain social distance
and wear a mask
all the time not when you feel like it
all the time when you're not eating and
drinking
but now the experts say with these
variants it's time to double up and
where to
this morning dr fauci and deutsche
endorse the idea on the today show
okay fine so fauci comes out
and supports the double masks i do want
to correct shepard smith here
he said that the experts told us to wear
masks from the beginning they didn't
tell us to wear masks from the beginning
they actually explicitly told us not to
wear masks from the beginning
fauchi said it was stupid to wear masks
and wouldn't do anything
and the surgeon general of the united
states said in all caps
multiple exclamation points stop buying
masks people so
shep got that completely wrong but fine
afterward then they said we all have to
start wearing masks
then they continue with their brilliant
report
experts say you can double up with a
tight weave
fabric mask for added protection now
virginia tech researchers found that
doubling up these cloth masks
increases the efficacy from 50 to 75
percent
a three layer mask could block up to 90
percent of the particles
and if you're layering your mask the
disposable surgical mask goes on first
and then the tight fitting fabric mask
goes right over the top
and then you can put the burka over your
head
and then you won't have any particle
come at you at all and you'll be wearing
a burlap sack
and then then we'll finally be safe then
we can get back to normal
when we're all covered not just in full
niqab but full burqa
then we're all back to normal here in
america follow the science
now you know i'm i'm not a obviously i'm
not a
scientist in a certain sense i guess i'm
an expert scientist but
you know i don't have a fancy white lab
coat i don't have some
sinicure at some administrative agency
but and just hear me out
if the the one and then the two
and then you do the three what it
should we just should should we
quadruple mask
is that because because that lady on
shepard smith's show
says that two masks is 75
effective now what does that mean
effective i don't know
it's just a number you know from some of
the geniuses with their spreadsheets
and then three masks is 90 effective
so by my mic that's a 15
increase so by my calculation four masks
would be a hundred and five percent
effective
and i don't want to be too ambitious
here
five masks right follow me that would be
120
effective can you imagine how much
healthier you would be
you'd be 20 healthier than you are right
now man you
i don't know you could live to be 110 at
that point
so i'm going to keep trying to work out
my theory of masks it seems that the
the fouchy scientific technocratic
theory of masks
keeps changing day by day but i'm going
to keep working out mine too i'm going
to come in here tomorrow i'm going to
have 20 masks on my face
i'm going to be the healthiest man in
america if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video